One of my dad's favorite things to eat was pie.
He loves sweet pies and he loves savory pies.
So that was one of our fall dishes,
was a savory pie. So that's what I'm making today.
I'm making a beef pie with our beef soup bones.
They're very meaty. Our butcher leaves on a lot of meat,
so we seared those and got those slow cooking.
Then I diced up some of our bacon and mushrooms and cooked those down,
added those into the beef soup bones,
and then we added some carrots and leeks,
bunch of garlic, onions,
and then we sauteed those.
And then after that, we added flour,
some maple sugar, a little bit of vinegar,
a lot of apple cider, some bone broth,
and then a bunch of herbs.
And we added all that back into the pot with the soup bones
to slow cook for a few hours.
Then I got started on the rough puff pastry.
So I added everything to the bowl,
formed them into some balls,
and let them sit for a little bit,
and then we started rolling.
So we roll out, we folds,
then we roll out again, we folds,
and then we roll out a few more times and fold,
so you can achieve those beautiful crispy layers,
flaky layers on your pie. And then the beef filling was done.
The beef was fine off the bones.
It was so good, it smelled incredible.
So roll that a Rough puff pastry,
laid that on top, we did a little egg wash and some scoring,
and then into the oven it went for 35 minutes,
or just until it was bubbly and golden brown.
While that was cooking, we whipped up some mashed potatoes and peas,
because the three of them are the ultimate fall comfort meal.
Um, after we plated it,
I sprinkled some of our French salt and pepper on,
and it was the perfect finishing touch.
Was so good. 10 out of 10. Perfect fall meal.